-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing
well tonight.
Let's get to the news.
Former President Trump filed
a lawsuit yesterday
against The New York Times,
three Times reporters,
and his niece Mary Trump
for disclosing
his tax documents.
But he might've
given away the game
because he is suing for
"100 million untaxable dollars."
[ Laughter ]
After former President Trump
filed the lawsuit yesterday,
Mary Trump said
that her uncle is a "loser."
This first reported
by The New York Times.
[ Laughter ]
During his address yesterday
to the UN General Assembly,
President Biden spoke about the
upcoming World Climate Summit
and called on leaders to,
"bring their
highest possible ambitions."
Said Australia --
[ Australian accent ]
A knife that's also a beer.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new book,
Russian President Vladimir Putin
told President Biden
on a phone call that he was,
"upset that Biden called him
a killer" in an old interview.
Putin was apparently so upset
that two of his aides
committed suicide.
[ Laughter ]
According
to new court documents,
former President Trump's
campaign knew
that the allegations
about broken voting machines
in the 2020 election were false.
Well, could you have clued in
Mike Lindell?
Those machines made him go
full Joker.
[ As Lindell ]
Want to know how I got
these scars?
Sharp corners
on uncomfortable pillows.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview, British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson
admitted he has six children
and then,
in a hard-hitting
follow-up question,
they asked him
to name all of them.
[ As Johnson ]
Uh, well, let's see.
Well, there's Nigel.
Uh, Ian.
Likely a Colin, Walby, Parker.
[ Laughter ]
The luxury toy car maker
The Little Car Company this week
unveiled a child-sized
Aston Martin that will sell
for $120,000.
The name is Bond.
Unhealthy Parental Bond.
[ Laughter ]
Reality star Kylie Jenner
yesterday unveiled
the new products
from her Kylie baby line,
which include shampoo,
conditioner, bubble bath,
and lip injections.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's a huge drag
to look at.
[ Laughter ]
A winning Mega Millions lottery
ticket that is worth more
than $400 million was sold
at a pizzeria in New York.
Even crazier, they also sold one
of those slices
with ziti on top of it.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
Amazon announced yesterday
that it is lobbying
the federal government
to legalize marijuana,
so, now, it's called...
And that was the monologue.